[Música]
i
[Aplausos]
gracias a ustedes gracias es que el
buenas noches
para mí es un gran placer placer estar
acá esta noche agradezco enormemente a
todos los que hicieron posible que yo
esté acá
en mi gran ciudad que la amo
profundamente los invito a ver ahora un
pequeño corto de lo que fue mi última
gran aventura
[Música]
bueno estamos acostumbrados a ver
les agradecí a la larga cualquier
condición
en casa
tenemos queremos todos
bueno
cuánta cuánta conexión que hay en este
escenario con todo lo que pasaron acá me
siento muy identificado casi con todos y
más que nada con coco y con con todos
los deportistas que han pasado
de muy chiquito
me involucré con la con la naturaleza
mis relaciones gracias a mi padre que me
inculcó básicamente a transitar por la
naturaleza de muy chiquito cuando nací
me fui a vivir muy cerquita de aquí con
mis abuelos creo que mis raíces están
ahí y por eso mi compromiso con la
naturaleza
luego empecé a hacer deporte porque
porque yo era un niño un niño gordo un
niño donde
cierto en ciertos momentos me sentía
como
como raro como no sé si decir la palabra
discriminado pero sí creo que sí oa
veces es como que también se rían de mí
no sé lo sentí así en ciertas ocasiones
luego empecé a crecer poco a poco empecé
a hacer deporte porque lo necesitaba mi
cuerpo y empecé a hacer todo lo que es
instancias locales competencias cerca de
trevelin cerca de toda la zona cerca de
esquel
ya empecé a mejorar empecé a hacer
torneos provinciales luego
torneos nacionales hasta que podéis pude
lograr estar entre los mejores del mundo
con las carreras aventura con lo que mi
padre y mis profesores y toda un montón
de gente que me formaron
creo que
que la conexión que tuve con la
naturaleza es muy importante
este pude recorrer todo el mundo pude
crecer como deportista puede crecer como
profesional y en el último trabajo que
hice la última aventura que hice fue
esta fue el del río santa cruz fue un
proyecto que lo hice juntamente con
francos peláez y que de pronto tuve que
hacerlo porque
tengo un fuerte compromiso con los ríos
con el agua y sabía que están
construyendo dos represas en el río
santa cruz entonces salí a defenderla
sentía que tenía que hacerlo y realmente
estoy conforme por haberlo hecho no
estoy orgulloso pero estoy realmente
conforme porque aporte mi granito de
arena para esta causa el hombre es como
corrompe en la avaricia de querer tener
tener mucho y no se da cuenta lo que
destruye
yo creo que las riquezas están en el
recurso natural en los ríos en las
montañas
en los lagos
a su vez como dije antes yo era un niño
un niño gordito si de pronto
me sentía como raro
y en un momento tuve que salir no salir
a demostrar que podía que podía hacer
cosas importantes que podía
que podía ganar que podía hacer cosas
buenas
una vez me tocó salir en una a una
competencia donde viajes y al viaje a
cataratas del iguazú atrás de un camión
en la térmica de un camión tres días
dejando para ir a competir porque porque
nadie quería en mí porque no tenía
dinero para solventar mis gastos
y yo quería demostrar a todo el mundo y
quería más que nada
demostrar a mí mismo que yo podía y pude
y pude lograrlo
entonces
lo que
lo que yo le puedo decir a los chicos
que realmente se pueden que de pronto yo
tuve tuve la gran
[Música]
el gran valor de poder salir de poder de
querer fortalecer mi mente también
entonces
esto se lo agradezco enormemente a las
adversidades que tuve porque las
adversidades pude comprender que
realmente puedo sacar cosas buenas puede
hacer una mente muy fuerte y esto
gracias
a mi padre que me enseñó a transitar en
la naturaleza a mi madre que me acompañó
siempre y me sentí muy acompañado a mi
pueblo que me dio las alas para poder
salir para poder mostrarme el mundo y
que sea mi pueblo no me dio todo pero
estoy agradecido porque si mi pueblo me
hubiese dado todo yo quizás no hubiese
salido y en este momento yo me doy
cuenta de que de pronto
descubrí que
que es muy importante el logro y lo más
importante de todo es ser feliz así que
agradezco enormemente a todos y bueno
muchas gracias
[Aplausos]